OF THE CIVIL CASE WHILE THE
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION INTO HIS
BUSINESS DEALINGS GOES FORWARD
IN NEW YORK.
>> Bret: REACTION FROM GOWDY
JOINING US LIVE FROM GREENVILLE,
SOUTH CAROLINA.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
>> YES, SIR, THANK YOU.
>> Bret: I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE RELEASE OF THE MEMOS.
YOU HAVE A NEW YORK CONGRESSMAN
FROM THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
SAYING THIS:
THE RELEASE OF THESE MEMOS
ACCOMPLISHED LITTLE OTHER THAN
CORROBORATING MR. COMEY'S
PREVIOUS TESTIMONY.
YOUR REACTION?
>> I READ THE MEMO 6 MONTHS AGO.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR ALL
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS AND THE
PUBLIC TO SEE THEM.
IF THERE WAS ANYTHING REALLY,
REALLY IMPORTANT THE DEMOCRATS
WOULD HAVE LEAKED WHAT THEY LEAD
6 MONTHS AGO.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID IF ANY OF
MY ASSOCIATES WERE INVOLVED IN
THIS COLLUSION, I WANT TO KNOW
IT.
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THE RUSSIA
CLOUD THE DEMOCRATS KEEP TALKING
ABOUT WAS THE SALACIOUS
ALLEGATION OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT.
IT WAS NOT THE INTERFERENCE.
WE LEARNED MORE ABOUT JIM COMEY
GOING ON HIS MORALITY TOUR OVER
THE NEXT COUPLE OF WEEKS.
>> Bret: DO YOU THINK HE BROKE
THE LAW?
>> I HAVE NO WAY OF KNOWING.
UNLIKE COMEY I DON'T COMPARE
PEOPLE TO MOB BOSSES OR SAY THEY
ARE UNFIT FOR OFFICE OR SAY THEY
OUGHT TO BE IMPEACHED.
I TRUST MICHAEL HOROWITZ THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL.
LET HIM FIGURE OUT IF THEY
CONTAIN CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
>> Bret: IF THEY DID HE WOULD
HAVE BROKEN THE LAW?
>> NOT BY THE STANDARD HE SET IN
2015.
HE IGNORED THE STATUTE THAT SAID
GROSSLY NEGLIGENT.
HE HAS A REQUIREMENT IT HAS TO
BE INTENTIAL AND YOU HAVE TO DO
IT TO HARM THE UNITED STATES.
UNDER THE STATE HE SET IN THE
SUMMER OF 2016 WITH SECT
CLINTON, I DON'T THINK JESUS
COULD WIN THAT CASE.
>> Bret: IN ONE PART HE
REFERENCES CNN.
HE SAID MEDIA LIKE CNN HAD THE
DOSSIER AND WERE LOOKING FOR A
NEWS HOOK.
I SAID IT WAS IMPORTANT THAT WE
NOT GIVE THEM THE EXCUSE.
WE WERE KEEPING A CLOSE HOLD.
HE COULD NOT BELIEVE THEY HAVE
NOT GONE WITH THIS.
THIS IS THE PRESIDENT SPEAKING:
>> Bret: 5 DAYS LATER, IT'S
LEAKED TO CNN THAT THE PRESIDENT
IS BRIEFED ON THIS VERY THING.
>> YES.
I THINK COMEY IS RIGHT THAT CNN
WAS LOOKING FOR THE FBI TO HAVE
THAT MATERIAL SO THE STORY COULD
BE THE FBI'S INVESTIGATION AS
OPPOSED TO THE UNDERLYING
INFORMATION.
WHAT WE LEARNED A LOT OF PEOPLE
AT DOJ AND THE FBI WERE TALKING
TO THE MEDIA IN UNAUTHORIZED
CONVERSATIONS.
WE WANT TO KNOW WHETHER BRENNAN
OR CLAP OR BOTH KNEW ABOUT THIS.
WHETHER OR NOT THEY COULD HAVE
BEEN THE SOURCE FOR CNN.
>> Bret: WITH ALL OF THE NEWS
AND COMEY WILL BE ON HERE WITH
ME ON THURSDAY.
WHAT STRIKES YOU ABOUT THIS AND
WHAT HE IS TALKING ABOUT?
>> JUST THE DOUBLE STANDARD,
BRET.
WHEN HE WAS UPSET WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP HE LEAKED MEMOS TO SPUR A
SPECIAL.
WHEN HE WAS UPSET WITH LORETTA
LYNCH, NOBODY KNEW A WORD ABOUT
IT.
NOBODY KNEW HE DIDN'T HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN LORETTA LYNCH.
HE MADE A DECISION AWAY FROM
HIMSELF.
WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP ASKED, GO
EASY ON MIKE FLYNN, HE'S A GOOD
GUY.
THAT IS AN IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
WHEN BARACK OBAMA PRE-JUDGES THE
OUTCOME OF THE HILLARY CLINTON
INVESTIGATION OR THE IRS
TARGETING SCANDAL, THAT'S OKAY.
THE DUPLICITY -- COMEY SAID I
DON'T DO SNEAKY THINGS, EXCEPT
MEMORALIZE PRIVATE
CONVERSATIONS.
I DON'T LEAK.
HIS BOOK TOURISM IS A WEASELY
THING.
WOULD YOU ASK HIM?
>> I WANT HOROWITZ'S REPORT TO
COME OUT FIRST.
I HAVE A LOT OF CONFIDENCE IN
HOROWITZ.
I WANT TO KNOW IN 2016 WHY THEY
HANDLED SECRETARY'S CLINTON'S
INVESTIGATION INTO SUCH AN
UNPRECEDENTED WAY.
IF ME DIDN'T MAKE HIS MIND UP
BEFORE JULY, WHY DRAFT THE PRESS
RELEASE IN MAY?
I WANT HOROWITZ AND MUELLER TO
CONCLUDE THEIR PROBES FIRST.
I THINK PEOPLE WILL HAVE
CONFIDENCE IN THEIR PROBES.
I WOULD LIKE TO ASK HIM MORE
QUESTIONS UNDER OATH.
>> Bret: DO YOU HAVE A SENSE
WHEN THEY WILL WRAP UP?
>> I WOULD LOOK FOR HOROWITZ TO
CONCLUDE IN MAY.
I DON'T KNOW THAT AND HE WOULD
NOT TELL ME.
I THINK THE NATURAL RHYTHM IS IN
MAY WITH THE McCABE PART ALREADY
COMING OUT.
WITH MUELLER I HAVE NO IDEA.
IF ANYONE DOES NO, SHAME ON THE
MUELLER TEAM FOR LEAKING IT.
I DON'T THINK THEY DID.
>> Bret: YOUR REACTION TO THE
DNC LAWSUIT.
THERE ARE EVEN SOME DEMOCRATS
SAYING IT'S KNOW THE RIGHT MOVE.
YOU HAVE BEEN LOOKING AT THIS
STUFF.
A LOT OF INVESTIGATIONS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THIS MOVE
BY THE DNC?
>> IT'S THIN AS A WAFER.
BERNIE SANDERS SUING THE DNC FOR
CONSPIRING TO GIVE HER THE
LAWSUIT,
LAWSUIT
LAWSUI -
LAWSUI --
LAWSUI -- EL
LAWSUI -- ELEC
LAWSUI -- ELECTI
LAWSUI -- ELECTION
LAWSUI -- ELECTION.
THAT WOULD BE AN INTERESTING
LAWSUIT.
COLLUSION.
IF THEY WANT TO SUE RUSSIA
THAT'S FINE: I WOULD PREFER
THOSE INDICTMENTS.
IF THEY ARE UPSET WITH
WIKI-LEAKS SO AM I.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION.
THIS IS EITHER A FUND-RAISING
PLOY OR AN EFFORT TO GET PEOPLE
IN SILV
IN SIL
IN CIL
IN CIVI
IN CIVIL
IN CIVIL C
IN CIVIL COU
IN CIVIL COURT
IN CIVIL COURT T
IN CIVIL COURT TO
IN CIVIL COURT TO D
IN CIVIL COURT TO DEP
IN CIVIL COURT TO DEPOS
IN CIVIL COURT TO DEPOSE
IN CIVIL COURT TO DEPOSE TH
IN CIVIL COURT TO DEPOSE THEM
IN CIVIL COURT TO DEPOSE THEM.
>> Bret: WERE YOU SURPRISED THAT